بوتين يقولها مرارا وتكرارا
عقوباتكم لا تفيد بشيء سوى إلحاق
الضرر بكم قبلنا،
وموسكو ستتكيف مع أي وضع ستكون فيه،
فافعلوا ما شئتم!!! ..
الدائرة بدأت بدورانها على المواطنين الأمريكان،
فكيف ستخرج أمريكا من هذه الأزمة
التي دخلتها بقدمها؟
لكن لن تخرج منها إلا بإذن من الدب الروسي
كما يقول أنصار موسكو!!،،
..بايدن يرد قطر ستكون حليفتنا
من خارج حلف الناتو، فهل تكون قطر
التي هي بمساحة قرية في أمريكا
هي المنقذة لأوروبا بأكملها من فم الدب الروسي؟
...قوات موسكو تستمر في السيطرة
على المطارات الأوكرانية،،
والعرب من الشرق الاوسط يتهافتون للقتال
مع بوتين فهل وجدوا فرصتهم المناسبة
لينتقموا لجراحهم القديمة، ..
الغرب نحن لم نكن يوما السبب في حرب روسيا
على أوكرانيا لكن كييف ترى عكس ذلك..
فهل تجعل خيانة الأصدقاء لأوكرانيا،
كييف تتخذ طريقها نحو موسكو وتعلن الاستسلام؟
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين،
في اجتماع خاص يقول:
أنه سيتم السماح للمتطوعين الراغبين بالقتال
بالذهاب إلى أوكرانيا، في وقت أكد فيه
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرغي شويغو
أن "16 ألف متطوع من الشرق الأوسط
مستعدون للقتال في منطقة دونباس"
الانفصالية في أوكرانيا.
وأضاف أن هذه الخطوة مبررة لأن
"عرّابي النظام الأوكراني الغربيين لا يدارون
حتى ما يفعلون" ويجمعون علانية "
مرتزقة من جميع أنحاء العالم لإرسالهم إلى أوكرانيا".
جو بايدن يصنف قطر  رسميا
كحليف استراتيجي من خارج حلف شمال الأطلسي...
لكن بهذه الخطوة قد تضع قطر نفسها في
مواجهة روسيا والصين فهل تجرؤ قطر
على خطوة كهذه؟
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلن سيطرتها
على مطارين شمال غربي أوكرانيا،
واشتباكات عنيفة في محيط العاصمة كييف
وسط محاصرة القوات الروسية لها..
كما أعلنت موسكو السيطرة على مدينة
بوتشا بشكل كامل.
حرب أوكرانيا تفتح النقاش بشأن الدور الروسي
في مفاوضات الملف النووي الإيراني..
حيث طالبات موسكو بضمانات أمريكية
ألا تؤثر حربها مع أوكرانيا بعلاقاتها مع طهران..
فيما أكد البيت الأبيض ألا علاقة بين الحرب
الأوكرانية والمفاوضات النووية..
في سياق متصل، وافق بوتين على تسليم أنظمة
صاروخية تم الاستيلاء عليها مؤخراً
إلى الانفصاليين المدعومين من روسيا.
كما طلب بوتين من شويغو أن يقترح عمليات
إعادة انتشار عسكري على الحدود الغربية لروسيا،
رداً على تلك التي قام بها حلف شمال الأطلسي
(الناتو) في أوروبا الشرقية.
وخلال لقاء لاحق مع الرئيس البيلاروسي،
أكد بوتين أن "هناك تحولاً إيجابياً
في المفاوضات مع أوكرانيا"، كما قال
في معرض تعليقه على العقوبات التي يفرضها الغرب
على روسيا: "سبق للاتحاد السوفياتي
وأن تعايش لفترة طويلة مع العقوبات".
جوزيب بوريل رئيس الديبلوماسية الأوروبية:
نحن لم ندفع أوكرانيا لتذهب في حرب ضد روسيا،
أين دفعنا أوكرانيا لكي تدخل في حرب مع روسيا؟
نحن حاولنا منع قيام الحرب بشتى الطرق والوسائل..
وأكد بوريل فرض الاتحاد الأوروبي ما يكفي
من العقوبات لإضعاف الاقتصاد الروسي،..
ونفى بوريل إعطاء وعود أخرى للرئيس الأوكراني، ..
مضيفا لا يمكننا إقامة منطقة حظر جوي..
فهل تخلت أوروبا عن أوكرانيا في منتصف الطريق؟
(الأحداث والتطورات)
فشل الاجتماع الثلاثي بين وزراء خارجية روسيا
وأوكرانيا وتركيا الذي عقد في مدينة أنطاليا التركية،
في إحراز أي تقدم فيما يتعلق بوقف إطلاق النار
وإنهاء الأزمة بين موسكو وكييف.
وأظهرت المباحثات تمسك كل طرف بمواقفه،
ورفض روسيا أي منصة للمفاوضات
بديلة لمنصة بيلاروسيا، ومطالبتها بأن تكون
أوكرانيا دولة محايدة. في المقابل،
جددت أوكرانيا طلبها بأن تكون تركيا
دولة ضامنة لأي اتفاقات مع الجانب الروسي.
وعقب اللقاء قال وزير خارجية روسيا لافروف
: العم سام لن يستطيع تدمير اقتصادنا
ونريد أوكرانيا محايدة...
ليرد وزير خارجية أوكرانيا كوليبا قائلا:
قائمة مطالبهم تعني الاستسلام ولن نستسلم...
أمريكا تتجه لقطع العلاقات التجارية العادية مع روسيا،،
مع إعطاء الرئيس الأمريكي صلاحية رفع الجمارك
على الواردات الروسية إلى أمريكا. .
مستشار الريس الأوكراني اذا انهزمنا
روسيا ستمطر أوروبا بالقنابل
موسكو ترد على العقوبات:
بفرض حظر على تصدير السيارات
والطائرات المسيرة حتى نهاية العام الحالي
في الوقت الذي كانت موسكو قد حظرت أيضا
بعض البضائع والسلع الزراعية..
وستسدد موسكو ديونها بالروبل الروسي
إذا استمر تجميد حسابان النقد الأجنبي
للبنك المركزي والحكومة بسبب العقوبات الغربية
بوتين: لقد ذهب الغرب لحل مشاكلهم مع فنزويلا
وإيران. وفي الأساس لم يكن هناك داع للعقوبات
على تلك الدول،، أما نحن فسنضع  حلولا
لجميع مشاكلنا...
نقلت وكالة الصحافة الفرنسية عن مجموعة
السبع دعوتها الدول المنتجة للغاز والنفط
إلى زيادة إمداداتها. وأضافت المجموعة
انها تدرس إجراءات للحد من ارتفاع أسعار الغاز
بوتين يؤكد أن روسيا تفي بالتزاماتها المتعلقة
بتصدير الطاقة إلى أوروبا بما فيها الخط العابر
للأراضي الأوكرانية. وقال بوتين في اجتماع حكومي,
إن روسيا لاعلاقة لها بارتفاع أسعار الطاقة,
متهما الساسة الغربيين بالكذب على شعوبهم
والاختباء وراء قرارات العقوبات.
مؤكدا أن العقوبات كانت ستفرض على روسيا
بشكل أو بآخر..
وأضاف بوتين: سيتكيف الاقتصاد مع الوضع الجديد
وسنستمر في إيجاد بدائل للاستيراد في جميع المجالات..
قال الرئيس الأميركي، جو بايدن:
إن الأميركيين "يشعرون بألم جراء ارتفاع
أسعار الغاز والوقود بسبب حرب روسيا
على أوكرانيا".
وأضاف:
"لكنهم يعلمون أنه على الرغم من أنّ السعر
مؤلم اليوم، فإن التكاليف باهظة،
وستكون أعلى إذا لم نتحرك الآن
ضد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الطاغية بحد وصفه".
بايدن: بوتين راهن على تقسيم الناتو وتقسيم الغرب
وتقسيم الولايات المتحدة ولكن رهانه لم يكن صائبا...
فهو يواجه حلف شمال الأطلسي الأكثر وحدة
من أي وقت مضى، حلفا موحدا أكثر مما يتخيل..
الصواريخ الفرط صوتية هي جيل جديد
يستخدم في حرب روسيا ضد أوكرانيا..
وهي صواريخ تتميز بقدرتها على المناورة
في الجو مع سرعة خيالية تتعدى
سرعة الصوت بعدة أضعاف
الجيش الأوكراني: محاولات الجيش الروسي
لاقتحام العاصمة الأوكرانية مازالت مستمرة،
وموسكو تضيق الخناق على كييف شيئا فشيئا..
صور لإطلاق صواريخ تستهدف الأراضي الأوكرانية
من سفن عسكرية روسية..
مدينة أوديسا تشهد انطلاق صفارات الإنذار
بشكل كبير، والقوات الأوكرانية تقول
أنها دمرت مقاتلة عسكرية من نوع سوخوي
شمال أوديسا..
مساعدة وزير الخارجية الأمريكي للشؤون السياسية،
فيكتوريا نولاند: نهاية الحرب تأتي عند تعرض
بوتين لهزيمة استراتيجية كما يستحق،
وخسائر الجيش الروسي في أوكرانيا تشير إلى ذلك...
وحسب التقديرات فقد خسر الروس حتى الآن
٦ آلاف جندي ولديهم مشاكل في التجهيزات
وتحدث عمليات انشقاقات في الجيش
واهتزت الروح المعنوية لديهم...
من أين يأتي الأمريكان بهذه الأخبار يا ترى؟
نولاند: سنمنع بوتين من الاستفادة الكاملة
من النفط الروسي حتى يوقف حربه،
تتباين التصريحات وتختلف التهديدات
وكل يغني على ليلاه،
لكن يستمر التقدم الروسي على الأرض
ويستمر تقهقر أوكرانيا وحلفاءها الغربيين،
فهل تحسم الحرب قريبا؟